texte de loi a été adopté à l'assemblée
nationale après plusieurs heures de
débats adoption du texte en première
lecture avec le soutien des députés a
l'air om agir et modem ce projet de loi
doit permettre d'organiser la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 10 juillet
avec une période transitoire qui doit
durer jusqu'à l'automne et pendant
laquelle le gouvernement s'offre le
droit de restreindre certaines libertés
on parle notamment de restrictions sur
la circulation des personnes sur
l'accueil du public ou encore sur
l'organisation de manifestations et cela
jusqu'au 30 octobre
elle les oppositions de droite comme de
gauche s'insurge et s'alarme d'un état
de droit qui ne porte pas son nom
elle dénonce notamment un texte
liberticide et disproportionnée on a un
texte de loi qui nous dit que c'est la
fin de l'état d'urgence très bien mais
qui en fait par différentes mesures la
prolonge cette période avec des
interdictions ou des réglementations
d'aller et de venir du droit de
manifester est un des éléments quand
même important tout ça nous paraît
vraiment à contre-courant nous paraît
dangereux liberticide et ça ne nous va
pas évidemment on est quelques-uns à
avoir voté contre
essentiellement les deux les deux
premiers articles deuxième qui vise à
conserver les données
numérique alors qu'elle était censée
rester de manière provisoire tout de
même et puis le premier article là qui
empêche les réunions et les
manifestations ça c'est juste pas
possible en état de droit c'est
contraire à la constitution c'est
contraire à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme
de son côté le gouvernement se défend et
insiste sur le fait qu'une sortie sèche
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 10
juillet mettrait en péril la situation
sanitaire
ce texte permettrait d'après l'exécutif
de réagir plus efficacement face à une
éventuelle résurgence du virus en écoute
à ce sujet il ya elle bras une pie v est
député lrm des yvelines projet doit été
nécessaires pour accompagner la sortie
progressive de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire et pour pouvoir donner au
gouvernement les outils nécessaires au
cas où il y aurait sur quelques endroits
du territoire nécessité 32 décision dont
un texte qui est équilibré il faut bien
voir qu'il y avait plusieurs intérêts en
jeu et que d'un côté vous avez les
intérêts de santé publique évident et
dans tout le monde a bien conscience et
de l'autre côté il ya les libertés
individuelles et publiques et il faut
réussir à concilier ces deux enjeux et
c'est ce que nous avons fait depuis
l'origine aujourd'hui l'épidémie n'est
pas
r nous nous avons encore un virus qui
circule sur le territoire donc il ne
faut pas oublier les considérations
sanitaires qui reste essentiel et dont
il faut protéger les français donc la
conciliation est toujours à portée nous
avons un regard très vigilants à cet
égard ce texte de loi qui permette une
période transitoire de l'état d'urgence
jusqu'à l'automne doit maintenant être
examiné par le sénat ce sera à partir de
lundi prochain